cet homme a décidé de prendre tous les
risques
tous les samedis soirs il va relever
formidable défi vous tenir en haleine
pendant une heure pour vous empêcher de
zapper conserver son art d'image il est
prêt à tout non rien sont bons même la
qualité
ma
[Applaudissements]
avec l'amour tel que vous
avait jamais vu
rend pas ni le professeur rollin
sandrine la petit la fêter
le chien zappe
[Musique]
on
ouais ça va bien je me réveille
complètement ça fait une semaine que
j'étais là
m
messieurs bons
bienvenue sur le plant audard dimat
avant de vous présenter ce quatrième
numéro je voudrais m'adresser à ceux
pour qui le fonctionnement de l'émission
n'est toujours pas clair qu'est ce que
le principe cardinal c'est vous et en
téléphonant au 36 65 7 1 2 3 fait monter
lardy maths ou descendre s'il descend
trop bas
le chien est tuée je lui dirai si le
monde vous retrouvez la semaine d'après
le type de sujet que vous avez préféré
par exemple cette semaine un tiers de
sexe un tiers de violence un tiers de
bagnols bref la routine de la télé quant
à ceux qui n'ont toujours pas compris le
principe mardi matin je rappelle qu'on
s'en fout
pour présenter cette émission j'ai
toujours avec moi le professeur rollin
bonsoir profession
à propos d'un professeur j'ai entendu
dire qu'un certain nombre de gens se
demandent si je suis vraiment professeur
je réponds bah écoutez soyez logique est
ce que vous croyez qu'on m'appellerait
professeur si je n'étais pas vraiment
professeurs c'est absurde c'est un peu
comme si on appelait monsieur le curé
quelqu'un qui n'est pas curé c'est
impossible
merci pour ça merci à ma gauche bas mais
téléspectateur moyen bonsoir
une petite fille entre vous deux oui oui
on s'est permis de venir avec notre
petite capucine graby ces diplomates
bonjour thierry soir capucine tu as quel
âge bonjour et tu fais quoi
oh tu vas l'école oui oui dans quelle
classe ce n 1 cm
tu connais des chansons oui nous
enchante fahrion tout à l'heure non donc
on est venu avec elles passées comme il
ya des moments dans l'émission on
s'ennuie un peu comme ça ça nous
permettra de lui faire réciter sa leçon
qui de papables de temps quoi bien sûr
mais surtout quand le professeur
explique certaines choses et c'est pas
toujours très clair c'est compliqué on
n'arrive pas à comprendre toujours un
indice excusez-moi professeur à mais
c'est vrai à défendre décroche
non mais c'est sans gravité jean-pierre
c'est tout à fait normal la télévision
est par essence une discipline complexe
un web à vous voyez par exemple là j'ai
pas saisie
moi j'aime après coûter moins ample
alors avec nous aussi sandrine la petite
fille est devenue une vraie star
sandrine pas de sandrine à l'horizon
sandrine autres la vraie star de cette
émission vous la connaissez tous cesap
montpetit a pu mais de toutes les
régions de france des lettres nous
parviennent pour demander sa grâce
je n'ai qu'une seule réponse à faire
pour sauver ap continuer à faire ce que
vous êtes en train de faire
regardez hardy mal je dois dire que nous
avons été très heureusement surpris par
la réaction d'un certain nombre de stars
souvent des amis d'ailleurs qui se sont
mobilisés pour sauver zappe
parmi eux jean jacques goldman jeu
patrick bruel brigitte bardot bernard
kouchner richard bohringer et louis
chedid qui a composé une chanson pour ap
on les cours
plaisir montsalvy ces deux
je
un gp
y'a quelqu'un de jeune à
à
[Musique]
nous sommes sept
alors
les bilans de la semaine dernière mais
oui thierry en effet le bilan c'est
maintenant de tradition dans l'art
d'imagés bien la séquence qui a fait le
meilleur score la semaine dernière c'est
janet jackson c'était votre idée est là
thierry en trois émissions trois idées
géniales vous est ce qu'on appelle un
magicien de la télé malheureusement
cette fois ci ce soir tout magicien que
vous êtes j'ai bien peur que vous ne
puissiez plus trouver une idée du même
tonneau
détrompez-vous professeur au je me suis
dit n'y aurait-il pas un jackson blanc
parce que vous savez que michael jackson
se donne beaucoup de mal pour être blanc
celui-là et blanc inouïe ouais et
comment vous est venue cette idée
géniale thierry et si je peux me
permettre de vous le demander
j'étais au restaurant avec ma femme
j'étais un peu trompette pompe est
exactement vous mangiez koala des
côtelettes d'agneau professeurs et puis
soudain l'idée venait jamais suivi un
jackson blanc ça vous est venu comment
votre femme est blanche et les bruits ma
femme est blanche sa mère est ce que
c'est ça qui m'a jackson team était bien
tu rêverais silence et attend des boîtes
l'émission va commencer et je vois qu'on
repart tout de suite sur la variété
anglo-saxonne 1 ça commence à bien faire
non je n'ai pas à me calmer j'ai demandé
la semaine dernière au nom de millions
de gens du basket 1 c'est pourtant pas
compliqué ça alors samedi dernier vous
ayez eu but lui vous ayez été pris de
court un peu je veux bien mais là vous
avez quand même une semaine pour vous
préparer alors levé rien à voir du
basket exige du basket qui tue lentement
de pauline meyer mois poliment qui
tiennent vivre moi c'est le service
public
ces voix le public chinois
basket
il va y en avoir dans un coin voilà
voici joe jackson
et
[Musique]
ouais
non
[Musique]
m
il ne va pas
toi
[Musique]
total
humala
c'est
quelques mois
tu vaux
[Musique]
d
au fond
oh
[Musique]
iam
m
j'ai moi même
mais
[Musique]
et ce qui ne va pas vous n'avez pas
l'air dans votre assiette là
je pensais à la villa on est enfermé
dans son studio à tous les samedis soirs
et pas contre vous mais la vie est
courte un conte guérit maintenant mais
la cie se trouve cependant ça se trouve
sur train de rater un truc truc super au
bistrot du coin puis celui-là moi ça me
plaît
ça me fait flipper quoi je pourrais je
sais pas il pourrait se passer des trucs
dans la rue on prend bien
j'y vais non non non tu rigoles non ça
ne se fait pas écouter thierry ici vous
avez besoin de vous dégourdir les jambes
vous pourrez quand même patienter une
heure le temps de finir cette émission
vous avez cent soixante sept heures dans
la semaine pour vous promener
maintenant j'y vais franchement dans son
coeur et la malaisie j'ai appris c'est
pas raisonnable écouter
c'est bon
thury allons
[Musique]
et
m
au juste
ce mec a fait souffler un café ce but
oui ça va vite ensuite ya dix ans quand
même merde elle ces écrans [ __ ] mais
je suis tiare dix ans m
pardi
[Musique]
les amis mes amis des amis mes amis s'il
vous plaît mes amis votre capitaine
thierry ardisson a eu un léger malaise
il s'est absenté quelques minutes je
vous demande de ne pas céder à la
panique et de rester à vos postes
pour passer le temps et pour nous
rassurer nous en avons besoin
nous allons chanter tous ensemble une
chanson une souris verte qui courait
dans l'herbe
je l'attends peut paraître je la montre
à ces messieurs
c'est les yeux mais qui traduit la dans
l'une il rempile à dans l'eau salée
hop
salut clan va bien thomas nouvelle
émission at il aussi bon à part et bien
ce petit studio à se lamenter trop assez
bien ces sympathiques
ce complexe oui j'ai un bon jeu égal
comme maintenant moi j'aime bien je
trouve que pour le regarde plus le
contrôle oui j'appelle danza comme par
hasard comme parasite arrêts et qu'est
ce que tu fous là d'un rush mettre en
page prend le jeu sort un petit peu le
vide par non le problème partout
maintenant je peux que les chiens de me
prendre une part pris moi je suis sorti
j'en ai marre en plein milieu de
l'émission on ira le bol ah ouais ouais
je me suis cassé et a décidé d'aller
faire un petit tour d'honneur que le
bistrot là bas voir un café très bien
fait en plein milieu de l'émission c'est
bien il faut faire comme ça maintenant
pu laisser diriger
il faut faire ce qu'on veut la télé je
crois que faire ce qu'on veut sinon j'ai
eu des nouvelles de toi là pour les
journaux là quand tu as fais là
la route mandarine a sauté sympathique
ça maintenant c'était très agréable
l'effet meyer qui si même pas cheap le 1
est vraiment j'ai passé quinze jours
désagréables qui m'ont permis de
remettre beaucoup de choses en question
et repartir sur d'autres bases je suis
sûr que ça a été un grand déclic pour
moi j'attends avec impatience en fait
finalement demeuré bars et dans bien
donc ça parce que là je me retrouve
vraiment et oublier la la presse
française un peu là-bas je crois que moi
je les oublie pas vraiment je crois que
c'est plutôt la presse française qui
nourrit un peu donc tendue en weppes à
part parce qu'il nous sort en ce moment
on est tous dans le même journal j'ai vu
wayne justin moi j'en fais pas beaucoup
de presse mais moi je cible
voici de ces drogues j'ai trouvé ça
plutôt sympathique
j'ai vu un truc fou dont on voit ici
t'as pas vu il ya bowie qu'avec été avec
une fille qui s'appelait à la vidéo
était une fille ça pnj
ouais et quand il avait divorcé de la
grossesse elle lui avait fait un deal et
pendant dix ans elle pouvait elle
pouvait pas parler d'eux il a payé du
poignet elle pouvait pas parler pendant
dix ans il s'était dit au bout de dix
ans vas y aura plus de problème au liban
elle y pensera plus tu vois le nas et au
bout de 10 ans lui sort en tout cas
elles sont un dossier explosif aussi
explosif où elle dit que
un jour elle est rentrée chez elle et
elle a trouvé son mari david bowie au
lit avec mick jagger
ça paraît un peu quatrième dimension un
peu c'est un peu bizarre ce qui est un
peu bizarre aussi c'est qu'on soit au
courant de ça et qu'on les lui et qu'on
les cons les regarder et c'est quand
même la démonstration d'une curiosité
malsaine qu'on a tous seuls malsain donc
la seule cour et on le regarde et on
sent et on sent par les uns les autres
et c'est comme ça que les canards comme
ça existe un peu dommage tu te souviens
de moi moi je me marre parce que quand
je repense à eux deux dans dancing the
streets et indigentes et la reprise même
timide the street dont les jets d un
pensionnat si si bien sûr années 60
qu'elle années 79 à sais pas si loin
finalement je pensais que c'était plus
vieux et tu penses que ça vient de là
et en même temps et voilà
ça va ouais ça va ça va mais en même
temps j'ai vu que le deuxième single
était et est rentré dans le top 50 non
il est rentré il en est sandy et à
sortir il va bouger on comprend plus
très bien comment se passe le top il ya
eu un chamboulement et là on sait plus
très bien ce qui à quoi ça correspond
donc on attend un peu de voir que ça se
stabilise mais
mais bon on est quand même c'est quand
même un drôle de
un drôle de système et on est dans une
drôle de spirale où quelque part tu peux
quand même remettre en question sa
créativité quoi te dire mais attend j'en
suis à cent mille albums ça fait ça fait
quatre mois que j'ai 25 ans je rome il
ya des tas de gens qui me font à taper
un disque et tout vivre alors attends
comment faut qu'on travaille je ne sais
pas très bien comment ça se passe
ça fait cinq ans je suis là dedans et
j'arrive toujours pas à piger ça vous
amuse bien marché naturel produit 45 n'a
finalement non ah bon il s'est bien
passé je suis moi et 20e 15e un top quoi
mais moi je m'attendais vraiment à un
plus gros carton de cette chanson je
vais pas écrire etc elle existe depuis
longtemps et d'un seul coup et je vous y
attends ça faisait longtemps que j'avais
entendu une chanson aussi bien écrites
on est en fait ça n'a pas bougé il ya un
canadien qu'il a pris pratiquement en
même temps je ne savais pas lui il a
fait le premier en charge pendant quatre
mois et les chansons de l'année là bas
et nous et nous ça n'a pas bougé alors
après on analysant un peu on se dit ah
les gens qu'on fait un peu l'amalgamme
avec ma vie privée et ça j'en peux plus
de l'amalgamé je vais bientôt plus
pouvoir chanter une chanson d'amour sans
qu'on dise que c'est pour quelqu'un et
qu'il ait vécu dans le fait un peu
terrible jeu vers la télé beaucoup n'ont
pas trop jusqu'à demain soir sur tf1 ils
ont été entendus un peu j'ai vu un peu
de pub je crois qu'à 37 2
j'en ai un bon tracé nice le sait les
heureux dix30 et là dans l'île robella
dans l'eau ça va râler
touchart bin hammam
non la mère béatrice dalle je manque sa
passe à 20h30 à la télé manson on se
trouve pas le prénom est mort ouais tu
regardes canal jimmy un peu non pas trop
je regardais j'avais le câble maintenant
ça va regarde plus trop la télé j'ai
plus de maison je suis un peu à droite à
gauche avant de l'homme
j'avais trop de souvenirs qui
m'embarrasse et la vie alors moment je
me suis détaché de tout ça et j'ai vu
comme ça le temps de leur credo de
basses dans sa mercedes
il ya un truc sur canal jimmy est
vachement bien qu'ils fassent qui est
passé hier soir qui passe le vendredi
ils savaient le dream ne connaît pas à
pas douter c'est un truc très marrant
c'est un truc de john landis
c'est un mec qui vit dans la société
moderne ça parle des problèmes
d'aujourd'hui la sexualité sida etc
et c'est un mec à regarder la télé
tellement jeune que chaque fois qu'il a
une pensée
cette pensée les illustrés par un bout
de film là une référence des années
vingt deux années de france des années
40 50 60 par exemple le mec il avec une
gonzesse qui lui dit ça y est on va le
faire on va le faire alors la bonne
femme le regarde comme ça tu vois il ya
un plan juste un plan en noir et blanc
des années 40 ou 50 au tu vois une
américaine qui fait marriage 3 et 4
comme ça tu vois et puis après il lui
dit non c'est le test du sida
on a fait un bon en même temps c'est
très drôle et en même temps c'est très
intéressant
c'est notre culture c'est la pierre rien
qui ne soit illustré ya aucune pensée
qu'ils soient illustrés par un petit
bout de film
assez marrant ça commence assez génial
c'est ça j'avais envie bien ça
s'arrangera john landis il vient la
technique aussi plus il a ramassé plein
plein de plaintes qui doit de regarder
regardez ça ouais ce vendredi soir il
n'y a pas longtemps c'est certes il n'ya
pas longtemps est sorti en france oui
hélas vacances d'été au vietnam a chopé
un peu nous annonce pas tellement on est
vraiment éloigné quoi à la culture
éloignés et même je suis pas j'aime bien
l'eurasienne mail asiatique complète sa
trompe pas dit quand même oui déjà moi
je suis supporter mais ils sont pas non
plus et non sur le coucher barça n'ont
pas trouvé montrer qu'il ya des très
belles femmes quoi la gorge parle pas la
langue et moi de ma séduction il se
faire vraiment en communiquant fort
boyard doit arriver tu dis pas il vous
plaît si tu crois à ça mais j'avais eu
ne trouve pas beau et je me trouvais
avec peut-être un peu de charme je crois
pas même un mois dans les années 70
j'avais beaucoup à mon pote ben quoi on
a traîné là bas elle est mon corps qui
choque pas tu payes non mais pas pour
pas trop chauffer pour maladie pour
traîner et dans les années 70 ça devait
être j'ai été très marqué par sa moelle
à aller je me souviens qu'une les uns
des films s'il ya longtemps mais à des
films qu'elle puisse marquer et emmanuel
je t'en souviens des manuels dire que tu
as vu emmanuel abandonne ouais c'est à
dire que moi j'ai vécu les papous
emmanuel est sorti quand même à oui et
je me souviens qu'il m'avait tellement
marqué la scène d'amour dans l'avion la
wii à l'époque j'étais une mauvaise je
vais demander de se faire couper les
cheveux pareil qu'emmanuel se faire
peindre comme al les cheveux et toutes
les conneries c'est l'effet complet
complet à dire jusqu'à ce qu'on baisse
dans l'avion comme emmanuel du top
le show de jay z antennes alors avions
n'ont jamais non forte dans un avion est
arrivé de d'avoir des histoires dans les
freins parce que quand je venais quand
je suis arrivé à paris tous les
week-ends je repartais en haute savoie
j'ai fait ça pendant deux trois ans donc
tous les week-ends il m'est arrivé deux
fois et d'avoir des aventures des flirts
dans le chemin donc c'est plutôt rigolo
qui rencontre la personne pendant le
voyage et la fin du voyage à flirter
avec et tu la retrouves mais bbc dans un
des lieux tu vas voir emmanuel le
nouveau nom elle nous voulons sur le
vrai et seul a beau regarder l'asile
braga
à bas coûts
g
c'est shawn ans un ancien des tensions
adoré ça m'étonne pas mais c'est sardi
match venait pas non je suis allé voir
ça vient de commencer
c'est bien mais j'espère que ce sera de
la même trempe que tu nous a fait passer
comme d'habitude c'est à dire que chaque
fois que je commence une émission tout
le monde me dit qu'elle est moins bien
que la précédente sahraoui quand j'ai
fait lunettes tout le monde a dit ce
témoin vient de bain de minuit quand
j'ai fait doubler justement à risque est
moins bien que les lunettes la simple
c'est un peu moins bien ses missions
alors l'idée c'est de passer comme ça
c'est vide et enfin l'argument c'est un
mec qui veut faire de l'art dit matt
donc il pour sa balance des bouts de
films toutes sortes de boutiques et bien
sûr que vous aimez les extraits de longs
métrages des déchets pas moi des dix
copies tonnes l'équipe des reportages
tout ça tu vas il ya un chien qui
s'appelle zappé prochain on le tue s'il
hardy matt descend le flanc à bien les
gens regardent à cause de s'en voir le
chien perdu le voir le plateau la
fiabilité mais je reste à voir
maintenant bien bon alors j'aimerais
banja il arrive
sow
mata b disait cela d'aller vite au sol
je te montrer un moment j'ai montré mon
plateau un plateau d'art du mat
voilà c'est là ça c'est mon public
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est mes téléspectateur moyen
irène et jean pierre professeur rollin
france soir là bonsoir
et puis moi tout moi tu me connais ah
oui stockage lsi là bas je vais y aller
a donc c'est pas le taulier de tout chez
moi le taulier ouais c'est là que je
bosse bon bah je vais vous laisser ça à
l'air d'être sympa moi c'est bien c'est
sympa merci fort avec plaisir et bientôt
de soutien vous allez me thierry ouais
un peu mieux oui chabrier
chaque semaine depuis un mois j'essaie
de vous parler de sexe à la télévision
sans encourir les foudres de la
direction de la chaîne et du csa alors
ce soir en direct live son plateau la
rue
agouazi eric et amélie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
et
qu'ils ont les positions intéressantes
mais ce n'est pas à la portée de tout le
monde la priorité de notre société se
doit être l'éducation
[Musique]
oh
on
m
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose de vabres 20 heures aussi
si thierry ça va très bien les choses se
présentent très simplement
vous avez passé 35 secondes d'emmanuel
coefficient à 8 54 secondes d'éducation
sexuelle coefficient 3 je ne vous
raconte pas les acrobates je suis gentil
26 secondes de beineix coefficient 7
total vous devez 24 secondes du
documentaire culturel sur venise et ses
musiques après cet intermède aussi
fleuri que parfumer les palets
reprennent leurs fiers démarche
ivre de la beauté de leur propre image
qui se reflète depuis des siècles dans
le frémissement du canal un frémissement
que seul claude monet son cheval est
planté sur un quai moussu saura saisir à
la pointe de son pinceau magique je
crois un professeur qu'après ça pour
sauver le chien ya plus que la potiche
mais où est-elle je laisse aux usagers
peuvent et sandrine non parce que c'est
pas tellement pour elle mais c'est
surtout pour l'audimat qui est en train
de chuter effroyable gens bien avec
venise sandrine en faire et pourquoi
sandrine mais qu'est ce qu'elle a
sandrine on a perdu la potiche
sandrine qu'est ce que tu fais quoi
qu'est ce que je fais mais pourquoi tu
viens pas tu m'avais promis
oui quoi promets que je ferai autre
chose je commencerai comme ça en prenant
la température que tu m'a même envoyé
des lettres tu m'avais promis
qu'est ce que tu veux je veux faire
autre chose chose que quoi autre chose
que de prendre la température de ton
studio en permanence tu peux mesurer
tout ce que tu veux si tu veux c'est
vrai tout même en poule alors c'est bon
d'accord c'est d'accord échanges 3
alors tu règles et ces règles et là tout
est arrangé on peut continuer on peut y
aller
formidable oui beaucoup de
téléspectateurs problème la montmarie
les contemplations basket mais moi la
gauche cela tient plus aveugle elle veut
absolument des jeux électroniques et
j'en ai pas un bon mot très fort on va
voir ce qu'on peut faire un d'accord
merci beaucoup de téléspectateurs se
demande ce que devient patrick sabatier
depuis son éviction de tf1
voici la réponse en images
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et j'imagine
oui cent des 95 centimes
merci sandrine merci petite forêt des
images cruelles tout comme celles qui
vont suivre et qui nous montre un
patrick poivre d'arvor victimes de la
convoitise de ses collègues pour la
présentation du journal de 20 heures sur
tf1
[Musique]
c
pas joli joli
oui sandrine ça va très bien c'est mon
plonge quoi oui je suis très très
heureuse de vous apprendre que cette
passerelle fait 50 55 centimes merci tu
te sandrine ça va merci beaucoup
pas joli joli donc mêmes qu'en fait pda
décide de prendre quelques jours de
vacances
voilà ce que ça donne
entend lui n'importe quelle voiture
d'abord il peut vous arriver quoi
adieu
[Applaudissements]
chez hertz les voitures en moins d'un an
hertz les voitures sont révisées avant
chaque location
et maintenant on applaudit consiste
en suisse
francis dhalleine bonsoir francis
comment se passe cette tournée à travers
la france est-ce que tu n'as pas un
petit peu assez francis de le faire des
scandales sur les plateaux de télévision
dans l'unique but de te faire remarquer
mais le prends pas mal francis
ça il est vexé francis nous fait braire
un professeur utile aucun humour ce
francis francis le prends pas comme ça
francis comment se passe cette tournée à
travers la france bien elle se passe
bien cette tournée francis will se passe
bien elle se passe bien
que vous allez voir maintenant est à la
limite du supportable
il a provoqué un débat au sein de la
rédaction mardi matin fallait-il le
diffuser ne fallait il pas le diffuser
finalement nous avons choisi de le
diffuser ce jour là les champions du
monde de saut en chute libre avait
décidé de prendre tous les risques
jusqu'à ce que leur parachute s'emmène
mais regardez
m
cotis
deux parachutes se sont croisés puis
entremêlées s'était coincé par les bras
la gorge visage il fallait que l'autre
coupe ses fils pour me dégager le visage
car j'ai tout fait nous étions
effroyablement mêlée alors que je me
débattais pour me libérer je me suis
souvenu que j'avais un couteau
j'ai coupé les liens assez rapidement
alors
ces jeunes parachutistes s'en est sorti
sain et sauf ge est soulagés mais un peu
déçu quand même avouer et c'est
justement ça le problème
la semaine dernière nous avons diffusé
des images terribles d'un meurtre en
direct et c'est à ce moment là
précisément que nous avons réalisé l'un
de nos meilleurs scores
alors non pas embêtés ça nous fait pas
plus plaisir qu'à vous met l'art dit
matt nous y oblige cette semaine encore
nous allons diffuser des meurtres en
direct mais là on les a tous mis d'un
coup les plus célèbres comme ça on sera
des bases au printemps de 1981
le pape jean paul ii fait le tour
habituel de la place saint-pierre avant
l'audience générale du mercredi
mais dans la foule quelqu'un se prépare
à l'iac qu'à un turc d'extrême droite
déjà meurtrier dans son pays va pointer
son revolver sur la silhouette blanche
il dira par la suite qu'il voulait tuer
le commandant des croisés jean paul 2
le pape s'est affaissé il a reçu trois
balles dans le corps dont l'une dans
l'abdomen
il ne perd pas connaissance et prie en
polonais il était 11 heures 50 lorsque
monsieur mohamed boudiaf président de la
cour suprême d'algérie prononcer un
discours devant les représentants des
structures départementales d'annaba
président sera l'anglais site officile
minutes après le début de la séance
il ya une très forte explosion suivie
immédiatement par des coups de feu tirés
par un homme en uniforme de la garde
présidentielle se situer derrière la
tribune officielle comme siège de
président
[Musique]
kennedy a quitté l'estrade pour échapper
à la cohue de ses admirateurs il est
allé dans une pièce près de la cuisine
de l'hôtel ambassador de los angeles où
se tenait son congrès vous voyez ce qui
est arrivé cinq secondes après les coups
de feu
[Musique]
voiture du président était trop en
avance je ne voyais plus quand les coups
de feu ont retenti
mon supérieur m'avait donné les
instructions suivantes en cas de danger
sauté de la voiture et tiré
c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai tiré j'ai vu
des gens touchés au sol les motards
s'agitait c'était le chaos
je me suis dirigé vers la limousine du
président on l'avait déjà évacué mais il
y avait des résidus de cerveau dans la
voiture c'était le jour de la
célébration de l'anniversaire de la
première attaque par les troupes
égyptiennes et forces israéliennes qui
occupait le signale une parade militaire
était organisée pour marquer l'événement
l'attentât fut commis en fait par un
commando infiltrés dans les troupes
censées supporter et rendre hommage au
président sadate les officiels n'ont pas
tout de suite compris ce qui se passait
en effet le bruit de la fusillade était
couvert par celui de la parade aérienne
six soldats sortir des camions
d'artillerie en jetant des grenades et
en tirant sur la tribune
sur cette image fixe ne peut voir un des
terroristes qui visent directement sa
date les cameramans se cacher et 30
secondes après le début des tirs les
terroristes continuer à tirer
c'était encore libres alors que les
rescapés attendent et des ambulances il
n'avait pas pris conscience de la mort
du président
et encore il est super
or en fait coucou à ses biens et avoirs
voilà
voilà on sait bien ce meurtre a été
filmée par an qui fait partie de
l'équipe dardy maths mais n'en profitez
pas pour faire pareil ça peut être
dangereux ne filmaient pas de meurtre et
non voyez pas vos cassettes à hardy matt
93 rue du faubourg-saint-honoré paris
8ème professeurs oui c'est bien thierry
manifestement excusez moi ce sont les
meurtres je crois qu'ils me
kibarou le disait manifestement le crime
paye nous avons gagné près de 26% des
architectes et plus de 80% des savoyards
maintenant pour conforter notre avance
il nous faut jouer une carte maîtresse
et là vous savez que la séquence qui bat
des records d'audience
traditionnellement c'est la météo
nous allons donc diffuser la météo mais
tant qu'à faire de faire de l'audience
j'ai choisi la météo qui a fait le
meilleur score de ces dix dernières
années
c'était celle du 3 janvier 1988
regardez
[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir comme promis nous
assistons à un changement de temps nous
allons vers le froid mais très lentement
très progressivement à tout petits pas
c'est une politique qui va durer au
moins deux autres à jour changement de
régime et ce régime de froid devrait
apparaître à partir de lundi et mardi
même si certainement mercredi les
températures qui vont chuter de manière
vertigineuse
alors avant d'envisager la journée de
samedi à dimanche un petit coup d'oeil
sur l'image satellite
c'est l'ancienne image la première on a
fait une petite révision des 1000 km
donc voici l'ancienne image satellite et
mais elle dit la même chose
elle vous montre cette progression est
allé se demi-cercle nuageux il s'est
arrêté ça y est il est 17h30 18h30 et
non
or plus fort gélard max lui la semaine
je vous ai promis au début de cette
émission que vous allez voir leur amour
tels que vous ne l'avez jamais vu la
voici
ils sont amis les banquiers sont très
bien habillé c'est pas l'idéal pour lire
du racing on va voir leur vas-y donc
j'ai promis que vous alliez voir nos
amours tels qu'ils n'avaient jamais vu
la voici le vin mauvais nous lire un
petit bout de britannicus il a su me
toucher seigneur et je n'ai point
prétendument caché cette sincérité sans
doute et peu discrète mais toujours de
mon coeur ma bouche et l'interprète
absente de la cour
je n'ai pas dû penser seigneur quand
l'art de feindre il a fallu m'exercer
britannicus et seuls quelques ennuis qui
le pressent ils ne voient dans son sort
que moi qui s'intéressent et n'a pour
tout plaisir seigneur que quelques
pleurs qui le font quelquefois oublier
ses malheurs
merci beaucoup
est-ce que la drague sur l'or dans le
public nous le réaction leurs regards
sont tes impressions sur la prestation
de vains mots
les fragments bien coller cette grosse
[ __ ]
senna vente et espérance à thierry enfin
de faire un peu de culture
vous avez vu la réaction des gens va
écouter c'est à vous dégoûter de faire
de la culture vraiment un
je suis effondré l'a pas puisque c'est
comme ça plus que tu vas plus de culture
voilà vous aurez lova moor mais plus de
culture merci laurent
[Musique]
vision si à peine
sexe et la violence
montrez pas une bagnole apprend la
caisse
il demande thierry le métro 31 cm
pas mal
ils ont demandé encore alors écoutez
l'histoire de rome années sert il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je crois que sandrine voudrais vous dire
quelque chose salehi sandrine
l'ordinateur mais la vraie 31
ouais par 14 par six ses cendriers pour
être un mythe il faut mourir jeune
mais en 1955 quand il tourne la fureur
de vivre
james d ne le sait pas encore
[Musique]
oh
ouais
[Musique]
alors céline
à mesurer non mais je crois que j'ai une
idée il est l'amour tout à l'heure à ma
place cette place yom hashoah je
mesurais mon tour de poitrine de leur
amour attention 120 bravo son brio les
bagnoles à fond la caisse c'est bien
gentil mais un jour ou l'autre c'est
l'accident
et après l'accident ya pire le garagiste
pour échapper aux garagistes une seule
solution acheter nourrissent tous
d'accord montre moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et il ya un matois kerry les scores sont
plutôt très bon mais il ya encore trop
de gens qui ne regardent pas la
télévision ce soir
je ne sais pas ce qu'ils font il faut
absolument se renseigner là dessus celle
en quête de notre jeune reporter bonne
bellanca mois cherche des belles femmes
mais si je veux dire tu vas pas en
trouver rassure toi tu vas pas en
trouver dont tu serais mieux quand même
devant hardy matt l'émission tir
ardisson quoi a redit m bah ils ont
ardisson il m'énerve un peu de temps en
temps
fais gaffe parce que tu vas dire quand
même parce que bon c'est mon taulier
donc tu vois que je ramène un truc que
sympa le slogan démission si vous zappez
il est viré tu vois sincèrement je n'ai
jamais regardé donc mais il faut pas
dire des choses comme ça quand tu es
devant la caméra parce que je te dis pas
les boules qui prend thierry si jamais
vous pouviez éviter de sortir le samedi
soir et regardez lui
ouais c'est bien parce qu'en plus il ya
un chien s'appelle zap et si jamais
l'audience des sens dessous des 15 % et
tout chien donc ce serait une bonne
chose quoi
chien sérieux tu essaies de faire un
effort quoi ouais d'accord patrolin faut
pas que ça se reproduise le théâtre
samedi soir d'accord très bien au
cinoche et on va dîner dehors
donc si vous pouviez éviter de faire ça
le samedi soir oui qu'est ce que je
ferai c'est l'histoire d'un gars des
arts divatte l'émission thierry ardisson
intimâtes c'est quoi ce que j'ai à cliff
et ont un peu bête
enfin c'est quoi hardy matt intimâtes
autant pas bien pas problème de
séquelles journal cd mixé présentant ses
pour la radio si jamais l'émission tu
vois baez
ardisson et virez moi aussi ouais donc
tu essaie d'éviter de sortir le samedi
soir effectivement c'est ce qu'on fera
une bonne chose ou et évitent de sortir
ouais drague pas oui et tu regarde la
télévision hardy matt nous mais on peut
passer une radio là pour m'écouter faut
que t'arrêtes le complexe radio ce trou
là je vais passer une telle y pour le
voir bah oui tu donnes m comme chez moi
j'y serais tu vas passer à la télévision
numérique cassette vidéo
oui c'est super on a tout ce qu'ils font
dans des pin's am acad orléans qui passe
devant aucune radio qu'une telle est la
sicile attend directement si tu pouvais
dire direct à cnn faut arrêter le tu
fumes open en paix noms viennent boire
une bière et demi ah ouais d'accord se
sont très bien passées très très bien on
aime on aime on aime se moquer ouais il
en faudrait plus comme lui tout à fait
voilà comme moi non
ababou je ne sais pas on ne vous connaît
pas encore peut-être pas pourquoi pas
thierry série larry max est descendu en
dessous de la barre des 15%
sans rancune ap marian personnel
zap a tué là nous appeler tu l'as dieu
soit loué
[Musique]
combien été léchées par les
téléspectateurs
ça veut dire la vérité c'est que l'école
ne l'aimé pas vous honte route et les
actionnaires
[Musique]
non
pas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inhabituel abonnez vous il m'était
impossible